this is a production of Cornell
University
um so I started at Cornell
um fresh out of grad school this is July
1988 probably before a lot of you were
on the face of the Earth
um and when I started the Cooperative
Extension specialist here told me that
Growers were having trouble controlling
powdery mildew they weren't getting as
good control as they had in the past
pumpkins were a new and up-and-coming
crop this was kind of this was the
beginning of the you pick and the Agra
entertainment time so an important crop
to be working on
one of the big advantages that I've seen
in working here on Long Island is the
close interaction with Cooperative
Extension so it's been really a huge
asset to be able for me to be on top of
what the problems are for Growers to
work with extension on management at on
on Research together getting information
out to Growers so it's a it's a really
great uh a place to be located
um you can see the characteristic
powdery mildew symptoms on the leaves
around being this picture that that
white growth is predominantly wind
dispersed spores
so if you use targeted fungicides
applied weekly top of the slide you'll
see um really great control a lot of
good green leaves here in early
September and here's non-treated control
and your first thought might be well how
do we mildew it's only affecting the
leaves why is it important to control it
in a crop like pumpkins
well if you don't control powdery mildew
the fruit is not going to have as good
color you can see this one's not quite
as dark orange but much more importantly
The Vines are going to die back early
and therefore the handle is going to
turn brown and start to rot and people
like to when they you pick pick up their
pumpkin using the handle or technically
the peduncle
um and want to have a nice attractive
handle so that's a big reason to control
powdery mildew with um pumpkins
with other crops it's even more
important with melons and uh winter
squashes you don't have as much sugar
stored when the vines die down
prematurely melons are not going to have
flavor winter squashes aren't going to
store as well so a lot of reasons to
control powdery mildew in all the
cucurbit crops
so when I started the first thing I
wondered is could poor control be
because of fungicide resistance I knew
the pathogen had already developed
resistance to Ben Light which was the
first targeted fungicide that had been
developed that's a Frac one fungicide
Frac groups are and that stands for
fungicide resistance action committee
different chemistry goes into different
um chemical groups and they're called
Frac one
Etc of different numbers for those of
you that aren't familiar with Frac codes
so the product that Growers were using
it at the time when I started that had
stopped giving them good control was
bailaton that's in a different Frac
group Frac three
um only targeted fungicide they had to
use at that point in time and I was
looking through some efficacy data that
other university professors had
published and was seeing some early poor
control in the um late 1980s uh
towards the time that I had started um
here at Cornell
and then the other thing that really had
me thinking fungicide resistance is
while I was at Penn State as grad
student I had volunteered to be the AV
person so I could attend this big
International fungicide resistance
Workshop
that was conducted at Penn State so
fungicide resistance was definitely on
my mind at that point in time
so we needed techniques
um so first step was to develop
techniques for looking at fungicide
resistance
powdery mildew it's an obligate pathogen
so we the only way we can maintain it is
on uh Leaf tissue developed this
technique taking cotyledons uh putting
them on water auger sometimes they'll
actually root there and we can maintain
the isolates um right here directly on
the cotyledons
which is the first kind of interesting
thing about powdery mildew because if
you look at cucurbits growing in the
field you will never see powdery mildew
on um cotyledons you won't see powdery
mildew until the plant is stressed and
that's typically by fruit production so
very interesting that in the lab we can
work with powdery mildew on on can on
cotyledons Technique we developed was
this laboratory Leaf disc assay we
basically take plants that's called lean
stage spray them with different
fungicide Solutions then the next day
cut out discs from those cotyledons put
them in these quadrant Petri dishes on
water auger give them 7 to 14 days for
the powdery mildew to grow and then look
at the severity on our control discs
compared to the fungicide treated discs
so that's the whole technique and it
works pretty well because the cotyledon
of of cucurbus is a nice fat tissue so
it really survives quite well on these
discs
so here's the situation when I started
um resistance had probably developed to
um bailaton active ingredient
tridemaphon in about around 86 so about
two years after the product was
registered for use that's pretty quick
and no these dates are not accidentally
reversed resistance had been detected in
the pathogen five years before the
product been late actually made it to
the market and that was detected in um
Geneva so I'm kind of was carrying on
the tradition of Cornell being involved
in looking at resistance in this
pathogen so we clearly didn't understand
much about resistance back in um 72 when
when Ben Light was registered was looked
at maybe this was just an oddity that we
were picking up isolate well the
scientist who was working on it before
me picked up isolates that were
resistance uh resistant didn't know what
it was going to do for control certainly
an awful lot we didn't know back then
about fungicide resistance
so the thing to notice about cucumber
but powdery mildew is it's really happy
on the underside of the leaves you can
see the colonies here are much larger
than the top side of the leaf it's going
to develop a lot better there
and this is where these new targeted
fungicides were really giving us
benefits in managing powdery mildew
they're able to move to the underside of
the leaf and control the powdery mildew
there
so if you were to spray a pumpkin crop
or any cucumber crop with a contact
protectant kind of a fungicide like
copper or
chlorothalanil you're going to get
control on the top side of the leaf but
very poor control on the bottom side of
the leaf and that's because with these
big leaves the spray deposit lands on
the top side it's really hard to get it
to move to the underside of the leaf and
these products can't move through the
leaf so if you don't control powdery
mildew on the underside of the leaf this
is what the leaf is going to look like
too soon it's going to die no powdery
milled on the top side but plenty on the
bottom that's causing the leaf to die
prematurely
so we're quickly finding out with Ben
Layton and Balaton and the targeted
fungicides we've gotten since is they
are so important for controlling powdery
mildew on the lower Leaf surface
their single action site of a single
site mode of action
um
this allows them to be able to move
through the leaf if you had a copper or
chlorothalanil moving into the leaf it's
going to damage the leaf tissue but
these these targeted fungicides can move
through the leaf
translaminoid or systemically and not
damage the leaf because of their single
site mode of action unfortunately that
single site mode of action means they're
prone to resistance
so back when I started in um 19 1988 in
the 1990s I'm starting to really look at
fungicide resistance
um
we had the foundation for General
recommendations for managing fungicide
resistance had come into play then and
and they're really what we have today as
our foundation for managing fungicide
resistance so first and foremost having
an integrated Management program so
you're reducing your need for fungicides
the number of pathogens you could use
rotation doesn't work with cucumber
powdery mildew it produces a wind
dispersed bore
um gets around very easily so rotation
is is not a play
um when I started we did not have much
for resistant varieties they've been
developed a lot since so not much else
we could do for reducing our need for
fungicides with cucurbit powdery mildew
next general recommendation is to
alternate amongst single site mode of
action chemistry
um so that you've got different
chemistry out there to kind of slow down
that resistance development
um well at that point in time when I
started all we had was bailaton and Ben
Light and we had resistance to belts so
we didn't have a solution there
the next is to combine our at-risk
fungicides with our broad spectrum
fungicides chlorothal and Ill copper so
that's that's our general resistance
Management program out of luck back in
in 1990 for what we could do so solution
I was able to do for Growers was to
obtain what is called a section 18
emergency registration and it was able
to get it for two fungicides that were
then effective for powdery mildew one
was a new Frac three fundsicides so
that's in the same group as Balaton but
it is more inherently more active so it
was effective against powdery mildew and
then a new brand new chemistry that was
just coming on the market Quadris which
is a Frac 11 fungicide
since then um EPA has said they will not
no longer accepts it accept applications
for Section 18s for two new fungicides
so that was a very unique time but it
did enable Growers to control powdery
mildew
um a little bit about some of the other
research that I routinely do one is
evaluating fungicides and I have a
tractor sprayer as you can see here I've
had a couple over the years so that I am
spraying similarly to what a grower
would be doing and having a big plot
um part of my goal is to see how well
the the at-risk fungicides are
performing over time so I will test them
each year
um just applying them every single week
gives me a chance to see as resistance
is developing is it affecting control or
not
but it's also important just to be
evaluating fungicides for Growers and
that's because registration of
pesticides unlike
um when a new drug comes on the market
for managing diseases in people
the efficacy of the product is not
considered in registration so it's
important to be able to get this
information for Growers and and to
important for me to be able to come up
with the best management programs for
them and I've found sometimes a product
we think is going to be really super
effective is not and actually one of the
most recent examples was a new Frac 3
fungicide that was thought inherently to
be a lot more active than the other ones
that came on the market and I found that
it was not and um so it is for some of
the other diseases that's been looked at
but just to show you this there's a lot
of reasons to be doing fungicide
evaluations first and foremost as I said
for for seeing when resistance is
impacting control
another technique that I developed was
doing the seedling bioassay and this
entails treating seedlings with
different fungicide concentrations put
them out in a commercial crop or next to
my research plots for um a day to have
spores dispersed on them and then we
bring those seedlings back to the
greenhouse and about 10 14 days later
we've got enough powdery mildew on the
leaves to write them so this gives us a
quicker response of quicker data than
the labdis assay but what it's doing is
it's showing us what's happening in the
population so I can't see what's
happening with an individual which is
the advantage of the other technique
um so here we are with some results
um from quite a few years ago and you
know another just really interesting
thing about powdery mildew look at all
that powdery mildew on that non-treated
leaf those plants were out in the field
for about six hours and to me it's just
amazing how disease that leaf can get in
just that short amount of time but you
can see here just seeing kind of a range
of different sensitivities
um or just a degree of amount of
resistance that's present so at that
point picking up a lot of resistance to
fret Code 11 some of the DMI fungicides
not doing as as well and at that point
in time we were not seeing resistance to
boscolator or quintech just to show you
this whole range this was a trial I had
done in Pennsylvania this was kind of a
year that it was kind of um a giving
back period in that when I looked at
this job
um as a grad student I didn't know much
about extension and I went and talked to
the vegetable extension
um pathologist at Penn State it kind of
got a feel for what extension was about
and said boy I really like this
um well just before 2008 he passed away
due to cancer and there was a void in
their vegetable program so I tried to do
a lot of Outreach activities with
Pennsylvania extension specials kind of
my my give back to my um to Penn State
for my grad school days
so let's Jump Ahead fungicide resistance
and kind of all the things I've seen
over the years
um so here we are of of all the
different
um chemistry you know see all these
different frat codes that have been
registered over the years up until 2018
um
a lot of interesting stuff so quadrants
came on the market I mentioned that one
where I got into section 18 for it
when it first hit the market the company
syngenta thought there's really low
chance we're going to see a resistance
problem with this chemistry we don't
need a resistance Management program
they didn't have any restrictions on the
label on use
and look at this three years we picked
up resistance to powdery mildew in three
years and actually it was the second
pathogen resistance was picked up to the
pathogen causing gummy stem light in
cucurbits before the powdery mildew
pathogen which was thought to have been
the first
that was so that was very interesting it
was also a particularly interesting year
because I was on sabbatical even
Australia and decided I'm going to do a
little bit of keep a little bit of my
research program going and one of them
was maintaining the fungicide efficacy
trial and that's where we picked up um
resistance and and control failure
we've had a lot of Frac 3 DMI fungicides
come on the market
um and we don't have except for that
first one Balaton we have not had
control failures
some of the best chemistry now some of
the most effective fungicides on the
market now are in that group so there's
it appears the fun the pathogen can't
develop enough resistance to this it's a
multi um Gene resistance as opposed to
the single site mode of action
resistance to the Frac 11 and the Frac 1
chemistry so that stayed on the market
uh first sdhi fungicide that came on the
market we had resistance in six years
quintech hit the market
um note one quintech is here first hit
the market we did have pristine and we
did have DMI fungicides we could
alternate with we didn't have resistance
yet still got resistance so we've got
alternation ability but we're not
completely preventing resistance from
developing maybe we're slowing it down
Torino was a particularly interesting
one for resistance to to hit we picked
that one up in five years
that one the company decided to have a
very robust label for resistance
management only allowing two
applications per crop I would have
thought that would have helped really
slow down resistance
um we have some other chemistry that's
remained on the market and and being
effective
schi Luna series flew a pyram is is
chemically a little bit different from
the other sdhis and I'll talk a little
bit more about that in a minute
so I'd mentioned that the broad spectrum
products like chlorophyll and copper are
going to give you good control on the
top side of the leaf um here is a crop
back back when Quadris resistance was
first picked up you can see crop looks
okay a lot of green leaves so Growers
were looking at this this is great we're
getting decent control
um so this is a fair amount of Education
I needed to be doing of the importance
of you got to look at the underside of
the leaf so there's another side of one
of those leaves white as snow
Bravo's working great on the top side of
the leaf no control on the underside
where quadrus is acting all by itself
um the sdhi fungicide so I want to talk
a little bit about how we've seen some
cross resistance with some chemistry and
not with others so um I've done some
work where I've tested multiple sdhi
fungicides so this is with an isolate
that is resistant to that first SDA sdhi
fract7 fungicide that came out bosculate
so it's able to grow on bosculid discs
with no problem at all it's also able to
grow these isolates on
disks that have been treated with two
other sdhi fungicides but not with
fluopyran so it's a little pyram
um binds a little bit differently so
there isn't complete cross resistance
these are the kind of things that are
really important to know to be able to
advise Growers you know what what other
fungicides can you use in this case
um none of the other sdhi fungicides
except for fluopyrion
another thing I've been finding um a lot
of recently that is pretty alarming is
isolates with multi-fungicide resistance
and we're detecting this through that
leaf disc bioassay by testing isolates
to multiple different chemistries
so um I have frequently been finding
isolates that are fully resistant to
frac one which isn't being used anymore
which is um pretty darn interesting that
that resistance hangs around so no
Fitness cost and I think you can see
from these discs
um that the pathogen is growing quite
well on fungicide treated discs as well
as on the control I don't see Fitness
costs
um so fully resistant diffract one
um to the bosculid of Frac seven which
would also be some of those other
cross-resistant prac seven chemistry
Frac 11 Frac 13 and U6 fungicides
so that's a little
unnerving when it comes to management
because I'm using any one of these
fungicides is going to be selecting
isolates they're resistant to the others
um I do find some isolates that are only
resistant to a couple different
fungicides not all of them but it means
your alternating program is just not
going to be as solid as we'd sure like
it to be
the other thing I wanted to point out is
is by fully resistant what I mean is in
those Fungicide bioassays and the lab
disk bioassay I am using and also in in
those field seedling assays we're
applying in the lab is the full field
dose in other words the concentration
that is in a grower spray tank so they
are fully resistant
I'm often finding particularly recently
that these isolates with that are fully
resistant also exhibit some reduced
sensitivity to our newer fractory
fungicides the floral pyram
um and also our Frac 70 fungicides so to
give you an example
here is a sensitive isolates from some
recent um assays that we've done so you
can see it's growing fairly well on the
control disks
um occasionally do we do get an escape I
don't consider this to be tolerating
that concentration we require seeing
growth on at least three discs to say
that it is resistant so you can see
absolutely no growth on on any of these
other chemistries that that were being
tested
and here's a resistant isolate
um so it's growing well on Torino Frac
U6 frax 13 quintech
um andorofract seven it's also growing
on a lunar privilege and rally at the
same concentration that was tested with
the sensitive isolate those are those
are partially resistant not fully
resistant and that those are not at
Field capacity field uh dose rate so
it's it's a slightly higher uh you know
a slightly higher rate than
um what the sensitive isolate can
tolerate but not enough that we're
seeing an impact on control so there is
the question of whether we're going to
continually see shift with some of this
chemistry or not
um always more to do
the other thing I've done is to collect
isolates from Growers fields to try and
get a feel for presence of resistance in
their field
um and this is a more recent work trying
to see do I see shifts uh potential for
shifts because of what they've used and
what I want to point out here
um a couple Growers where they've used
quintech twice in rotation
and they've got 67 to 100 percent of the
isolates from those fields that we
tested were resistant to quintech
whereas the field were just protectants
were used or quintech once were picking
up no resistance to quintech
and then the other thing you will see is
some high resistance percentages to the
freck seven fungicide Endura although no
Frac seven chemistry has been used here
and that's because of that
multifungicide resistance so these
isolates that are resistant to quintech
are also resistant to Andorra
so back to that comment I made earlier
about the fact that we got a lot of
powdery mildew on the underside of the
leaf did not get in control with
protectant fungicides there next
question was is there any way we can get
our protectant fungicides to the
underside of the leaf better so that we
can get better control they can have
more of a role in resistance management
so I invested in an aerisist sprayer I
did some work with uh the AG technology
person who was at Cornell in looking at
different nozzle types air induction
twin Jets
um on a regular spray room plus this
aerisa sprayer we just tried all kinds
of things to improve control on the
under side of the leaves and I looked at
it in two ways I had plots that were
treated with um just Bravo can I get
more better control on the underside of
the leaves and we also did the very
simple procedure of putting water
sensitive paper on placing it on the
underside of the leaf or on the top side
of the leaf to see what we're getting
for coverage and you can clearly see
we're not getting much spray on the
underside of the leaves um it didn't
matter with that air assist spray or we
were not driving more spray material to
the underside of those big pumpkin
leaves unfortunately and it matched the
control
um more recently bio pesticides have
come on the market and I've gotten
involved in testing them
there are quite a few that are labeled
for cucurbit mildews both powdery mildew
and Downing mildew some of them
a number of them have a microbial active
ingredient
um there's a bunch that have a Botanical
active ingredient and some that are just
natural products
as I mentioned earlier EPA does not
require efficacy data for registering
any of these
um thus the value of testing them and
and seeing how well they work
and bottom line of what I found with
powdery mildew is they have contact
activity I'm not seeing control on the
underside of the leaves
a number of these products and
particular lifeguard and a number of
others that have bacillus they are being
promoted as inducing resistance
if they were inducing resistance in
pumpkins or any other cucurbit I think
I'd be seeing control on the underside
of the leaf which I'm not
um I think an interesting Next Step
could be for somebody who's got the
capability of looking at the plants and
seeing is resistance actually being
induced I think that would be a very
valuable next step with some of these
products
I see them from my work as being really
helpful for organic Growers they're
giving them a better solution than using
copper
um I'm still fighting to try to find how
they really fit well for a conventional
grower
so I also look at other ways to manage
powdery mildew there are resistant
varieties more so have come on the
market in in more recent years than when
I first started out
um here's an example of a variety trial
for varieties that were resistant to
powdery mildew in melons
um what I found with melons is there is
really strong resistance it's erase
specific resistance if you've got
resistance in the melon to race one and
two which have been the dominant races
that I've found when I've done screening
of races
um we're not seeing a big race war thank
goodness seeing some huge changes um
over time
okay is there a question
okay I thought I saw some heard some
other talking
um I see really good control with the
resistant variety of melon varieties
um Growers need to know how what kind of
control level they're getting with a
resistant varieties do you know how it
fits in a program I found with uh
squashes and pumpkins I get very little
control so a grower really needs to have
an integrated Management program where
they're grow using fungicides as well
just an example to show you uh
susceptible variety and the resistant
varieties kind of you can see sometimes
a range in how well they control powdery
mildew
um but it's important for Growers to
know the quality of the fruit because
that's what is they are selling
um the trials that I've done I interact
with the extension specialist The
Cooperative Extension specialist here in
the county she evaluate helps me with
evaluating the fruit quality so it's a
good interactive program one second
someone somebody has unmuted the
microphone please commute your
microphones
okay Meg please go on yeah sorry okay
um
grocery
so the the
kind of
things we do and I'll kind of point out
with this one because this is just a
fabulous uh result
um Trifecta was rated the highest for
overall fruit quality in our evaluation
and 21 and also the past year that comes
from the Cornell plant breeding program
from Michael Missouri so proud to see
that result
um some other research research um
activities I've had with powdering
mildew um over the years at one point in
time I had someone working with me in my
program who graduated from uh Cornell
focused on mycology and she helped
correct the name of the pathogen to
potestaria xanthia
we also noticed that um the pathogen's
sexual stage was present often in the
fall
um chasma these eye you can see these
little tiny black fruiting bodies on the
bottom side of the leaf
and we discovered that we could get them
to appear um on leaves um in the lab
um and actually it's very interesting
well once again another interesting
thing with powdery mildew well we don't
see this until the fall often after we
started getting cool temperatures at
night
you put two path isolates together that
are of opposite mating type and they'll
produce those chasmathesia
pretty much as soon as they've met each
other
um able to document
um as we proceeded with this work that
they're heterophallic
um looked at occurrence of both mating
types and found that they commonly do
occur together in a field
um at that point in time I'd gotten some
isolates from other areas in the of the
US and found the same thing
um my mycology expert partner at that
point in time was interested in looking
at whether the ascos 4 survived over
winter she was able to document that
indeed the leaf tissue in leaf tissue
they do survive there are some viable
ascospores in the spring that kind of do
decline a little bit over over the
winter
um but it's kind of important to think
about the whole overall biology and I do
wonder about the role in the life cycle
because a grower is going to plow down
their field in the fall typically that's
putting the leaf tissue into the ground
coming back with a cover crop and most
Growers are not putting cucurbits back
in the same field the next year
um
another really interesting thing about
powdery mildew is its Host range it also
goes to verbena
um they're not related I find this just
fascinating
um I took powdery mildew off of verbena
and moved it on to pumpkins and it grew
just fine just happy verifying that
indeed verbena is an alternate host
that's important because if you're
growing cucurbit seedlings for sale to
home gardeners in a greenhouse where
you're also growing verbena you could
end up with powdery mildew on those
plants you wanted to sell to gardeners
and it's also important because
sometimes there are different fungicides
registered on ornamentals and might be
getting some early selection for
resistance
um well I've had a lot of work every
year I've had experiments on cucurb at
powdery mildew and there's still plenty
of work left to do although this was my
last field season
um this past year I've also had time to
look at other topics
um when I got into right away when I
came to Long Island was looking at the
impact of ambient ozone on plant
productivity
um here out on Long Island we do see
high ozone every uh summer and that's
because of the car traffic that we have
and it was um this work I did was part
of a regional team of other scientists
here is a line it worked with two lines
of beans this is one that is not
sensitive to Ozone and we had a line
that is very sensitive to Ozone just to
see how much symptoms we get how much is
impact
um and the impact that I saw on yield
was um
up to and over 50
um reduction in B yield which is pretty
phenomenal
um I've also worked on cucurbit Downey
mildew after its re-emergence in 2004 we
believe believe a new strain of the
pathogen that came in at that point in
time which was able to overcome the
resistance in cucumbers
um and also had resistance to some
fungicides so all of a sudden the major
ways that Downey mildew was being
managed which was resistant cucumbers
which was the main crop that was being
hit and also fungicides we lost those
controls and Downing mildew has been a
major issue ever since and in all of the
cucurbit crops not just cucumbers so
some of the work I've done is looking at
efficacy of fungicides looking at
biopesticides evaluating resistant
variety so Growers know how well
cucumber and there's also a few
cantaloupe varieties are able to resist
downy mildew I've looked at integrated
programs so combining um conventional
fungicides on a resistant variety or
combining biopesticides with
conventional fungicides and looking at
kind of an integrated program for
Growers who might want to try to reduce
their use of conventional fungicides
I've been involved with the national
team monitoring the occurrence of
cucurbit downy mildew this is a
fascinating pathogen in that we know it
can survive over winter in South Florida
with the winter production of cucurbits
there it is not known to be surviving by
oaspores elsewhere and we can monitor
and track its movement up the East Coast
every year and to me that's just
phenomenal a pathogen able to move that
far every year often making it all the
way into Canada
thank God covet didn't move that easily
um and I've also looked at fungicide
resistance so you can see this is uh the
seedling bio assay is is the way I've
looked at fungicide resistance in cucurb
at Downey mildew out in a community in a
commercial field so you can see the
impact of Downing mildew Danny mildew on
cucumber and Danny mildew on cantaloupe
are the two leaves to the side
basil downy mildew new disease first
detected in the United States in the
fall of 2007.
um I've looked at efficacy of fungicides
biopesticide resistant varieties which
have um had their place and done a
really good job
um some of them here is a variety that
is has no resistance uh susceptible
variety here is one of the resistant
varieties I've looked at that has a very
high level of
um control but it's a single Gene
um and with that one we are starting to
see a breakdown of um its uh resistance
starting to see a new race of the
pathogens starting to appear so kind of
wondering if we're going to be on a
treadmill of trying to keep up with um
uh having resistant varieties that can
stand up to Basil downy mildew there are
some other varieties that have a
multi-genetic resistance so we do see
downy mildew on them all the time not
anywhere near as much as a susceptible
variety and that's a more durable
resistance so we'll see what happens
over time
challenge with a disease that's
affecting an herb or a leafy vegetable
is it this Fresh Market is it doesn't
matter if you got a lot of the pathogen
on it or just a little bit those leaves
are unmarketable
um so you've really got to have a high
level of control and I think that's
where
um very difficult to get control of Bio
pesticides I'm more looking at
biopesticides applied to a resistant
variety to try and see some control
the other thing I've been involved with
since it started
um this is having this disease is
monitoring its occurrence in the U.S
this is my most recent monitoring
program that I've got is is with the AG
pest monitor
um a group
and that's been interesting for just
learning about its occurrence gaining
more knowledge about the disease one
interesting case in particular quite a
number of years back kind of early in in
its occurrence in the U.S
um we're kind of wondering where this
disease had come from I guess I should
back up and say prior to detecting it in
the U.S it had been detected in Europe
um starting around 2001 and before that
it was detected in Uganda in 1930 33-34
so it's kind of this mystery disease
what had been doing all those years you
know why why hadn't it gone anywhere
else
um one of my reporters was from South
Africa and it was after the
international uh plant Congress and I
had met some people from South Africa so
I contacted them tried to get a hold of
somebody there just to learn a little
bit more about basil downy mildew
occurrence in South Africa and learn
from their extend attention person that
they'd worked with a grower
um in the late 1990s who was marketing
basil to Europe and having issues with
Downey mildew so I suspect it went from
South Africa to Europe and took off in
Europe
um it's a seedborn pathogen and that's
how it got to the U.S
um there's also been a number of new
diseases that I haven't done research on
but have done extension on one of them
is stem philium I've had actually a
couple stem filliums but stemphillium
leaf spot in tomato showing here a
contrast with septorially spot symptoms
and more common disease for us
stem philium is a disease that occurs
primarily in the southeast of the United
States it likes it warm and humid we
started seeing it very recently in high
tunnel production Tomatoes which is a
new way that we're growing tomatoes in
the Northeast in recent Years also
seeing a little bit of starting to
appear in the field so this may be a
disease that with climate change we're
going to start seeing more commonly some
of the other new diseases that I've seen
in recent years have come in on seed
particularly organic seed and that's
been a big issue
late blight I started working on that
after it's re-emergence in 2009
interestingly in recent years this kind
of disappeared again so that was kind of
the end of working on it
um you can kind of see here what happens
with the susceptible variety if you
don't apply fungicides a resistant
variety we can get some good control
I think interesting for me with this one
is just watching it spread in particular
in 2009 that was an outbreak that
started because a um
company that sells plants to home
gardeners had an outbreak in their
plants and they were selling those
plants
that was interesting but 2011 was
actually the most interesting year on
Long Island in that we had one company
in New England that produced plants for
one Garden Center on Long Island and
they had started tomatoes and also
potato plants for home gardeners their
potato plants had late light it spread
to the tomatoes
they called out all the tomatoes that
had symptoms sold the remaining plants
to a garden center on Long Island and
that one source led to a huge Outbreak
on Long Island it was actually even
worse in 2011 for us than than 2009 and
it was just interesting to watch the
spread of of this um pathogen and
disease on Long Island that year so a
lot of interesting things over the years
the other one I've worked on is by top
throw blight uh really started taking
off in the 1990s you can see what it
does to pumpkins that's been really
where it's hit hit the hardest
um also it causes a crown rod on
pumpkins blight hits other crops as well
I've looked at reduced tillage for
managing phytophthora blight and I've
looked at mustard biofumigation as well
as fungicides biofungicides
another new interesting that happened
during my career is seeing phytop throw
a ha jump to a new host snapping not
related to cucurbits or Peppers or
eggplants which are the other hosts um
here's symptoms on snap beans
um I've also done research on foliar
diseases of uh Tomatoes um fungicides
biopesticides resistant varieties
um fair amount of work in recent years
since Tom zitter who was in um Ithaca
had retired working with the Cornell
tomato breeder in evaluating her
experimentals
so um hopefully I've given you a good
feel for how interesting cucumber
powdery mildew has been and how well
it's been able to fill my career
um it's also been really rewarding uh
it's been rewarding just advancing to
science
um having colleagues thank me for the
work I've done but as I look back over
my career to me the most biggest reward
what's giving me the greatest
satisfaction is when other extension
faculty Cooperative Extension
Specialists but particularly Growers
thank me when I answer questions or give
a presentation and they they've liked
the work and um
when I see the amount of hits to
websites that I've got with extension
materials um to me that's been the most
rewarding so I guess for me an extension
position was um really valuable and and
I'm really thankful for the time I've
had in this position
and I need to acknowledge that I've had
a lot of people help me out over the
years
um I haven't had grad students because
I'm so far from campus I've had
um several technicians over the years
currently Colin is um the technician
who's working with me
um he's my eighth last best in a lot of
regards technician
um uh one thing shout out to Colin I
know you're on on the line and I hope
you're not you're not
um blushing there but to me what's been
really interesting is his background is
not in Plant Pathology he has graphic
arts as a background that makes him very
detail-oriented he's been very quick to
learn so it's kind of a message that you
can excel in a position if that's not if
even though that position is not your
background so um I'm very grateful to
Colin for and my previous technicians
for their help and I've also had a lot
of Summer students join me uh usually
college students this is Claire from
this past year she is a recent Cornell
grad which which is why I wanted to
include a picture with her and I think
we got a few minutes for questions so I
will stop sharing
so Meg thank you very much it was
wonderful and very nice to hear from you
very good snapshot of
a lot of work you have done
so now we are open to questions and
there are some questions I think I saw a
question from Juan uh in the chat
but also anybody in Geneva or on Zoom if
there are questions please unmute and go
ahead and ask
so I can start with the first question
so you want me to go ahead and read I
guess I could read it uh so given the
evidence of fast multi-fungicide
resistance stably stacking in some of
these isolates plus the non-renewable
character of most plant resistance genes
mechanisms it kind of feels like the
efficacy of management strategy is
slowly eroding yes I do agree
where do you believe we should be
focusing now before we get to the point
where we were before the 50s
um we do get good control now with the
fungicides we've got it is a question
will we see resistance to all of those
we're seeing new chemistry coming out
um so I
I'm I'm hopeful
um the biggest having resistant
varieties and that's where I'm hoping
that Gene editing Precision breeding is
going to become acceptable and we will
see advances and and better resistance
hitting the market
um I think that's going to be a real
Panacea because you can take a variety
that has all the characteristics a
grower wants and and edit it instead of
crossing and then trying to cross out
all the the bad characteristics to get
back to to get an acceptable variety and
I've seen that in evaluating the
material from plant breeders
particularly when I'm working with plant
breeders and early material often there
are some some issues with um with some
undesirable traits
um bazel for instance with Downing
mildew
um the parent had it was a spice type
that had a licorice flavor took time to
breed out that licorice flavor
hopefully that answers your question
speak up if it didn't
yeah I think Chris smart has a question
and very uh hey Meg uh hey Chris
it's a great presentation uh one of the
things I guess I wanted to highlight to
the group and then a question for Meg
the fact that Meg is on Long Island it's
a huge bonus for those of us who are in
Geneva and Ithaca because the
agriculture in Long Island is so
incredibly unique the soils are unique
The Growers are unique the amount of
traffic is you know everything about it
is different
um which has been great for us it's
great for us to have those folks there
and Meg has done an amazing job
um I guess my question Meg is is what
how do you how do you see egg in Long
Island
um you know do you I guess I see Suffolk
county is continuing to be a Powerhouse
in agriculture
um but I guess I'd I'd appreciate your
opinion and how has Disease Control
changed because you're on Long Island
and all of the requirements of Long
Island
well that's a big question
um we will all I think we'll always have
AG here I agree first of all the first
land preservation programs um started
here on Long Island
um so we have a lot of land that is
preserved from development
we have a lot of people who want to come
out and and
be come out not only to buy produce from
the Farms
um also to for the AG entertainment we
now have a lot of wineries distilleries
breweries people coming out for that
some of the biggest Greenhouse
operations are here on Long Island we've
got Nursery we've got sod a lot of
diversity
where I think past capacity for people
but there certainly isn't more room for
people so we need to keep the land and
AG from that perspective
um but but seeing people contributing to
land preservation there is a um Farm in
my town where people contributed funding
to preserve some of the acreage and and
keep that land um it was a farm that had
been split between the three children so
two of the children wanted to develop
their chunks and and were looking to
sell it for I think it was half a
million per acre so you're talking a lot
of money that people put into preserving
that land so that it could be kept it in
the farm some of the land
um so we we see we see those kind of
things happening we also have a lot of
aquaculture
um we still have a duck farm out here
um my my daughter who's associate
director with Long Island Farm Bureau
was continually reminding me of all the
other agriculture that is here on Long
Island
um
yeah there's a lot to do the Agri
entertainment in the fall
um I don't leave my house on a October
weekend you're not going anywhere unless
you're going to drive at like 6 A.M
thanks is there any other question
I guess the other thing I'd add about
Long Island island is given how
different it is I think that also adds
to the addition of
conducting research in New York
including Long Island the fact that our
soils are Sandy our climate is so much
more temperate we're entirely different
um
Zone planting zone than upstate
and we're going to see impacts of
climate change
more so
a question here in Geneva
have you looked up the impact of
foliar Leaf surface coverage on fruit
quality in terms of
contact protection fungicides and
systemics like if the upper surface is
completely covered or completely
controlled the lower surface is covered
versus
coverage on both surfaces do you see a
substantial difference in production for
Quality
I've looked at it with um cucurbits and
absolutely we do
um we we see so the major one I look at
continue to look at is pumpkins and we
don't see fruit with this good quality
our primary measurement is how the
handles go down so what percentage of
the fruit remain with a good solid
handle into early mid-september
um and definitely the leaves die back
and and
quality slips the other thing that can
happen if you don't have good
um a canopy cover when we get into the
fall we have more um do periods and you
can get do lasting on the fruit and then
you get an intense sunlight day nice
bright clear fall day and you can end up
with Sun's gold
I've seen a number of fruits lost to Sun
scald because of not having a good
canopy cover in the fall
so my the question is when you said that
all the basal heat with powdery mildew
could not be sold even if it's a small
spot
is that because of ethics for spread
legal reasons are customer preference
for product for perfect looking products
that's going to be a combination that's
downy mildew um first of all the case I
was confusing about that
um part of it is is absolutely I mean do
you buy leaves that have spots in in the
grocery store you're probably going to
avoid those the other issue with
marketing you'll often see bazel is
marketed either
um in a in a in a bag or in a clam shell
that's a nice moist environment a little
bit of downy mildew is going to become a
lot of Downing mildew very quickly so
that's another issue
okay so so with that I I think uh uh
first the announcement that uh anybody
who wants to talk with uh mag just stay
online and continue talking with mag but
we should really Applause Meg for this
amazing and beautiful presentation and
her career is really amazing so yeah
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu